there is a scene  that i would love the audience to see  that i didn't put in but it's a really  cool scene with that same unseen  prisoner in arkham batman because he's  getting these cards and letters from the  riddler and he's thinking why is this  guy writing to me i'm supposed to be  anonymous and he's putting a lens on me  i don't like that and so he goes to kind  of profile this kind of serial killer  and you see him meeting with somebody  who's obviously a serial killer himself  you're seeing a version of this  character who yes when you see the  unknown prisoner you're like well gee i  i think that's who that is well that is  who that is but he's not yet that  character so at some point i definitely  want the audience to see that scene just  because they could see this really cool  scene